alright welcome everybody welcome to
another business QA where we play league
of legends and answer your business
questions I am queuing up with my dual q
partner in crime fresh views Jason jrez
fonseka is also in the house playing
next to me today what's up Jay yo yo and
also joined by my co-host for the next
couple weeks I am Jennifer price with my
gonna meet myself there how you doing
Jennifer I'm doing great thank you
feeling energized today energized right
I love it well it's been it's been a
couple days off I've been a little sick
and also recording some audio versions
of my ebook so it's good to be back get
one in before the weekends and yeah so
what's the what's the fantasy of the day
today Jan what do we got well my fantasy
for for myself and for y'all is to find
ways to dance instead of destroyed I
might sound a little silly but I know
there's a lot of despair and frustration
going on in the country because of the
election there's also a lot of rejoicing
to but last night in portland's we had
several protests going on that turned
into riots and violence and people
breaking windows and spray painting cars
and all kinds of stuff of innocent
people and I just feel like it's not the
way to you know to get results and it's
you want to express yourself I think
that's awesome but you know do it
through through a different way and I
yesterday I got had the pleasure of
going to a dance class that so
therapeutic and it was all about moving
forward and taking action in our lives
and so that's what I would encourage you
all to do is dance find it before your
dances find a way to dance if you have
to spare and set up destroyed dance
instead of destroy like that what what
kind of dance class were you doing
yesterday it was a lyrical class which
is technically lyrical is really
anything that has to do with when you're
dancing more to the lyrics of a music
and it's more usually more storytelling
and it has in this particular style with
a lot of had a lot of sort of
contemporary and probably ballet
influence to the damn so we did without
it was amazing it was a Beyonce James
Blake song called called forward so
moving forward well tomorrow I'm so I
Toronto dance also we've got a new dance
team that I'm I'm going to be joining my
first lesson this tomorrow first classes
tomorrow I haven't been our dance team a
long time so it will be a fun fun
exercise so it will both be dancing like
I love it are you you guys perform on
the team or is it just more of a like a
group thing it's meant to be performance
team for its those for my instructors
and for the assistance in my classes to
give them an opportunity to continue to
learn and grow and learn some new dance
moves so one of our instructors is
supremely creative and so he's coming up
with the choreography it's going to be
teaching it and it's an opportunity for
everybody to kind of learn and pick it
up didya it's gonna be performance I'm
not a big fan of performing so I'm
probably not gonna go and perform but
I'm gonna do the image of the choreo
anyway and be part of the team so I'm
excited that's cool yeah yeah I hear
that go for you so so does your dance
instead of destroy tie into your quote
today or is that it was that the quote
it does tie into Michael a little bit
and my quote is from Maya Angelou and
the quote is if one is lucky a solitary
fantasy can transform 1,000,000
realities so you know have a fantasy all
and transform the world that way I love
it I love it cool we're in champion
select it looks like I'm going to t-mo
jungle and J reyez is gonna rise top and
I'm excited we're gonna hit the game
let's hit up our first question what
we've got alright cool so our first
question of the day
was a question from one of your earlier
videos on getting the patent and so the
question was hello service was quite
motivating and informative does one need
to patent and online magazine and I I
don't know the instruments I mean other
than I don't for intellectual property I
think you can get trademarks for the
name of the magazine but i think the
magazine it helps you don't need a
patent but I you know I'm certainly not
the expert on this so take it away of it
yeah see I mean you can't get a patent
on a name there would have to be
something super unique and different
about your online magazine compared to
every other online magazine it's gonna
be my you know everything inside me is
saying no this problem a like a ninety
nine point seven five percent chance
that it's a no but maybe there is
something just insanely crazy that you
can you can go and get packed it and
it's really just talking to a patent
lawyer yeah yeah if you're looking at me
from need to add more context to for
everybody else watching and listening
your patent if you're if you're coming
up with a new invention right patents
are meant to protect an invention for a
certain amount of time so you have to
have invented something new right
something that hasn't been done before
even just an addition to something like
that currently exists like if you're
making a new a new add-on for a car you
know you can patent that even I looked
at our company my first company was a
software company once you commercially
release something once you start selling
something then you can't get a patent on
it anymore and so our first version of
our software we couldn't get patented
but the second generation version we
could on the changes click the changes
we made reimbursed in the second those
we had a couple unique things that could
get patented but the core of what was in
the first version we couldn't
already commercially released so it's
basically looking at what is not
currently available on the market that
is super different and unique that you
know that's what you want to go out and
get patents so is there enough in an
online magazine are you using tools that
nobody's used before if you create
something that the world has never seen
before that's what that's what they can
I look for it's likely going to be
really difficult but if you still feel
like you have something that I'd
encourage you to talk to a patent lawyer
to figure that out yeah totally
otherwise I say go for it you know get
your online magazine going yeah I want
to see it yeah I think I should make it
happen I love it genocide this morning i
love it all right i just want to give a
quick shout out to the chat room yeah
we've got they know and how we've got a
bet you pro and of course uh of course
Jay and you and there's mitch mitch is
here too exciting guys thanks for being
here welcome so we are in a game we hang
out yeah okay go ahead Ozzy we're in
game i got my team of jungle jer Isis
top so we're starting it's exciting
let's see how it goes oh no guy go let's
keep my streak of doing this with you
guys when you win and what I could knock
on all right on to the next question and
this is from Mohammed and he says just a
question bro if I'm working in a market
that is filled with competitors but can
you anything just to make me lose for no
reason they want to compete themselves
only because they control the market and
this was a question that was on the your
sales technique video okay so um yeah I
mean I think it kind of goes back to
what we talked about a couple days
go here if you have a lot of competitors
you know just look at how you can stand
out against them what are the things
that you have that they don't and and
really highlight that and then you know
obviously in any sales situation you
know you got to detect your customers
and ask them a lot of questions and find
out what they want and then highlight
what you have is they want and you know
yeah that's my god Evan I was confused
by the question yeah I'm a little
confused on the question two is it looks
like what he's saying is it there's a
lot of competitors of control the market
that will make it really hard for him
okay well listen ah it does a big market
you're going to have lots of competitors
a lot of people don't get into a
business because they feel like there's
already lots of competitors in it you
know if there's no competition in the
industry maybe it's not a good industry
to be in like sometimes being the first
in an industry is not a good strategy
because there's no money to be made
you're too early what I would say is
understand that there is always room for
quality always in any industry yeah the
even the most like you could say hey I
want to get set it on YouTube and
YouTube there's already tons of people
all I'm gonna be uh I'm gonna be a
makeup channel you know is it well
there's already tons of makeup channel
so are going to be an entrepreneur
channel well there's already tons of
entrepreneurs channels there's always
room for quality always and so I spent
very little time thinking about what my
competition is doing I'm much more about
how I can make something better I think
if you're just focused on the
competition there was a really great
video i can remember who it was i think
it was simon Sinek who was we're just
doing a top ten on him he wrote the book
start with why if you guys are familiar
with that and he was talking about how
he went to apple and microsoft and he
was speaking at both of their events an
apple a lot of the sorry microsoft a lot
of the conversation was about
how we're going to beat Apple this year
how we're going to beat Apple like yours
why our tech is better than apples tech
like seventy percent of the
conversations about how to beat Apple
where Apple spent zero percent of the
time thinking about how they're going to
be their competitors and I think it's
telling in that one you want to be much
more like you don't want to be just
reactionary all the time you want to be
much more proactive in your approach and
I think if all you do is looking at the
competition and saying well look how far
ahead they are or you know they're
trying to squeeze me out of business you
know like that's that's a competitive
market you know people aren't going to
try to squeeze you out of out of the
business that's that's part of business
ya know late you just need to execute
you gotta do it better so that's what
I'd be looking at doing how can you do
it better there's always room in the
most competitive market there's always
room for you to do a good job and win
some business oh my god I love it good
stuff all right we've got a question
from the chat box I'm just going to jump
into let's see here believe teen oh
maybe in my bed MIT towards the chest
the people in the chat box so why not
i'll just i'll get your softness to what
are some books we can read i'm working
in online products we want to start
doing online personal development
coaching but we are not sure how to
market it as a lot of people tend to
prefer in person coaching so you want to
do some online coaching instead of in
person coaching anyone's know how to
market it uh-huh and what books to read
to market it and what books are ya okay
well i mean i think almost any any
marketing book could have applied for
online as well as in person i mean a lot
of the same principles apply you know
you got to think about what the
advantages are for you to do it in
online better than in person so for a
lot of people they might prefer online
they might like to
flushable they can choose anybody that
they want then I'll have to choose them
into live in their town to do it in
person there's all kinds of reasons why
doing something online it's awesome so
highlight what those are and use that as
part of your marketing yeah I'm trying
to get some of my favorite books but
nothing's come to mind right now
obviously you got a reason one word from
Alan right december six that's right
Kevin moon is coming up um yeah actually
I so so it there's a couple of things
here for me one if I were to pick a book
just on online marketing right now I
would probably go with the askgaryvee
book Gary Vaynerchuk wrote a poem are
too long ago a lot a lot of talk is
about online marketing in there a lot of
the problems with the online marketing
book so is there they're obsolete by the
time they come out right like even
Gary's book he wrote it you know two
years ago a year and a half ago and then
I look at my book I wrote it I was
starting writing there like two years
ago well yeah I mean my book is is meant
to live forever the examples are meant
to live forever but in an online
marketing world if you're looking at
there's some basics of marketing that
will never die but the exception will
change right like what you do on YouTube
versus what you do on snapchat versus
what you do on Facebook you know those
change constantly I look at the amount
of changes I've made just on my youtube
channel and how much how many changes
I'm making and still making you know if
I wrote a book two years about go about
YouTube marketing it would be so
different right now there's still some
consistencies in that yes you need to
make quality content and yes you need to
you know have a regular consistent
schedule but a lot of a lot of the
specifics would change so I don't know
that if you're looking at online
marketing I don't know that a book is
your best place to go I think just the
production cycle
too long unless you're looking for
timeless wisdom which can still help you
I don't think that the book is your best
bet I think it's better to pay attention
to people who are doing it I would watch
Gary's youtube channel as an example I
think you'll get better results now in
terms of lidocaine in terms of marketing
marketing and online business I would
start looking at so I mean it comes down
to your content and where can you make
help bottom line is have an interesting
time there where can you make working
you add your content so think about the
message if you want to put out about
coaching you know what's so different
about your coaching what's your what's
your unique message that you want to
bring out to the world and then how do
you want to deliver that are you good at
speaking are you going on video are you
great at writing are you you know better
doing interviews what is the format that
you want to share your knowledge because
you don't want to be everywhere but
chances are your customers are in a lot
of different places so I'd be looking
which other platforms that I want to
spend time on invest in my energy into
making some good content around so for
me I like to go all in on YouTube I like
making videos I like finding ways to
make me but even this is hey let's let's
have some fun and play some league and
also kind of so much prefers and make a
new video and so you know that's what I
default to you got to figure out what
where your market is for for your
specific skill set there's a lot of
opportunity on YouTube you know if you
made a weekly video or a couple times a
week video talking about coaching the
things that hold people back you know
how your coaching program helps the
common frustrations are people face that
you see if you made videos on that
you'll start getting some some clients
you'll start getting some interest
so summing all that working with here
should be all about the YouTube is
YouTube right yes really YouTube is a is
a default answer yeah so summing it up
buggy but if I had to answer the
question and pick one book would be the
askgaryvee book although I don't think a
book is your best spot to go to unless
you're trying to learn timeless stuff
I'd be looking at the channel that I
want to have success in so if you want
to have success on YouTube I've been
watching Gary Vee and other youtubers
about how they're having their success
if you want to are we fighting Oh II
fighter if you want to have success on
on Twitter then I'll be following people
who are really big on Twitter and
getting a lot of results there hey I
gotta kill very exciting Oh woohoo we
got it um yeah I know yeah you are not
find consistent content consistent
content consistent content on whatever
that platform is that you decide to go
all in on ya as we're talking about I
was thinking about a couple other
resources that might be good for you and
one of them is on my podcast the any
portable important field has out and
specifically all about techniques to use
an online marketing that must be really
great for it you know that's for more
for specific tactics but and then a book
that i have read it's really really good
especially for anyone any on some of
those just starting now and wants to
really feel out there market and we do
some research before they launch it to
make sure it's and if our customers
really want is a book called will if
flies from pat flynn and it's got some
really great ideas for both online and
its regular businesses so i would highly
recommend that book if you're such a are
in the beginning stages and just begin
to explore how to market something
whether it's online or not but it is
kind of focused more on line so that's
why they would maybe think of it it's a
really good one it sounds really good
amazing marketing basics but but you
know so will be good for anyone
alright I like it oh I got another kill
while we're talking like that and we
hear the cat again the cat came back she
did it's putting a couple people asking
the chat if she was here and i ever
stole i said no because she was upstairs
sleeping but as course as soon as i said
that she wanders in and is trying to
join the conversation of course
attention to that attention-seeker house
okay she was a chat so that's her thing
she hears me talking she's like oh I
gotta go to talk buddy um ok let's go
into the next question nah this was off
of one of your videos about apps how to
market apps and the question was hello I
want to this is from amazing TV hello I
want to ask you about if you know how to
stuff keywords in Android manifest to
rank our app so this specifically has to
do with the keywords in apps and i also
have no clue on this at all how that
works for ranking apps in ice and itunes
or or whatnot i obviously obviously it's
a good abs that's you know that's was
going to get it rates high sometimes
it's really key words so i don't know if
you saw seven yeah i i'm kinda in the
same camp ah if i look at my my videos
and in general my strategy it's it's oh
oh somebody died very sad I don't focus
on the SEO part nearly as much if you
make good stuff people will pay
attention like way more important and
keyword stuffing way more important is
making an app that people want to use on
a daily basis do that how do you do that
make an app that's so good that people
want to use every single day that's what
you want to do and I think that that in
general instead of looking for people
are always looking for shortcuts and I
get it but if I had to pick one thing to
focus on to help my apt take off
or my website take off for my youtube
channel take off you know if you're
making YouTube videos yes the titles
matter yes the thumbnails matter yes you
know do the this is description matter
yes it all matters but what matters way
way way way more is making really good
videos and so I would start there
because if I looked at your app there's
probably a ton of improvement and I
would bet that a lot of the a lot of
this the people using it right now are
not using on a daily basis and so before
you worry about getting more people to
come into your come into your app and
then you churn them out make your appt
better that's what I would say yes love
it the next question is also in regards
the same video and despite soon engineer
and he says I have an idea on an app
that will catch on quick and will Tran
fast because of something that millions
used every day but overlooked it how do
I push it to a company and I'm assuming
you're talking about pitching it for
funding to make the apps I'm thinking
which I know as I can talk a little bit
better about touching something I mean I
obviously just like Gavin said with the
last minute it's a really good half the
people will use a lot then it'll be easy
to pitch but I think to who if your keep
in mind your audiences and get you know
get user feedback it's gonna be a lot
easier to you know get something funded
I would think so those are my thoughts I
mean I think you know anything your is
under doing any kind of software app
development i think if you can you know
get user feedback directly it's going to
help you ton because it will help make
sure you're doing it in a way that will
convince people will use and you'll have
idea what they'll use aboard so you know
a little more clarity would have helped
but I don't you know I would not expect
to go in and expect a big company to
fund the development of your app
they're not interested in doing that oh
can we get something here when we get
something here no dear eyes is not happy
we'll see Lee sin is here we're gonna
meet up a big fight uh-uh-uh team was
gonna die team was gonna die oh wait
wait I may not die Timo Timo team will
died very sad very sad I almost got it
oh sad it's a very sad day all right
it's okay sorry for that delay there
yeah okay so I big companies not going
to fund your idea my take on it would
have been I think he's trying to sell it
to the company like I hope happened I
want to that company understand what
they are most interested in is not the
tech not the app and got the technology
it's it's the the audience but here's
what happens if they like it right if
they really love what your app can do
the CEO is going to look to the CTO and
say how long is going to take us to
develop that thing because i don't want
to pay a big price tag for this thing I
just want that functionality so if they
love what your app can do they're going
to say hey how how can we just copy
justjust even look at the uh you know
snapchat came along had these amazing
filters and now everybody's kind of
copying snapchatting Facebook's doing
their own filters and all of this stuff
right they like they do not want to pay
they're not going to want to pay you a
lot of money right they just would
rather get the functionality and build
it themselves so what what you can do
that they can't do on their own is have
an audience so what they want to see is
that you've done the extra work Oh
Oh team was going to die again no very
sad timos team will died two kills two
deaths on Tula what they want to see is
that if you have all these users using
this thing that they can't just quickly
go out and replicate the users they can
replicate your technology but they can't
replicate the base that you have and so
that's what you need to go out and do
you need to go out and get some momentum
because the complete company doesn't
want to just buy a bunch of code they
want to buy the user base so you have to
go out and get a user base and that
comes from if we tied the last question
making your product better right making
something that people want to use on a
daily basis Oh under attack made it in
and if you do that enough then you'll
get attention great if you focus on
making a really really great product
you're going to get attention and you'll
attract interest you know all the big
companies that I work with have all come
to me because of the attention that I
built up and so if you make something
that is unbelievable that people are
using consistently it's it gives you
first of all you're coming from position
of strength so it gives you way more to
work with and second of all you're going
to get a much higher likelihood of
getting a deal and a much better
evaluation because you have something
more than just an idea
so those are my thoughts what for Todd
check out the question with a little
little big though grantor my my team
just surrendered so it's game over oh
it's always a fast game with Jenny there
either we Louise surrender oh my god
that's what we broke our streets no
there we were 12 last food that's a
bummer that's all right that's okay all
right we'll give everybody a GG then
when you win fine thank you live that's
how it works you have a dance instead of
destroy a break that's right all right
so how is Jenny I'm always curious now
how is jen gonna wrap all of this up
into an amazing bundle for us here at
the end the final message Wow is yeah my
final message is you know this is going
to be kind of relatable enough but I
feel like it is related to to all these
questions and just any business and that
is to go out and talk to your customers
I think the more you talk to your
customers the more feedback you're going
to get and they're better your products
going to be the better your marketing is
going to be the butter everything is
going to be for you if you're if you
want to sell anything and you want to
get good service and good value so go
out and talk to your customers go taking
the copier send them an email apps
number for their opinion or or sit in
the survey whatever it takes very cool i
love it well thank you guys what you're
watching thank you erisin Jen chieh Jane
Jay Jay and Jay team for joining in hope
you guys have an amazing friday a great
close to the week we believe in you we
hope you continue to believe and rise
and fantasize what's ahead hey what
dance am in dance that much love the 30
season